My name is Max.
I am a partner manager for Google Play in Berlin.
My daily interaction is
Communicate with app developers
Please help me reset my notes?
Discussed throughout the emerging device ecosystem
How to develop a correct interaction strategy
Although from the current point of view
The main platform for your interaction with customers
Is a smartphone
But we think
A complete ecosystem of intelligent networking devices
Will become the main interactive platform
Such as smart TV
Smart watch, smart car
These devices will bring new ways for user interaction
We can see the development of beacon deployment
Although it is still in its early stages
But it will surely continue to grow and develop in the future.
And with the development of the Internet of Things growing
It will also create new opportunities for you.
Let you interact with users in the real world
We saw this slide in Mateo's presentation before.
I think this slide accurately captures the focus.
For developers, the key challenge is
Find the right strategy to get the most out of it
Evolving networked device ecosystem
We found after observing various categories of applications.
Interact with your app regularly
Helps build loyalty to your audience
Thereby having a better chance of cultivating long-term customers
Or establish a long-term relationship with the user
So today I will introduce to you.
In the era of "one person, many machines"
How to develop a sensible interactive strategy
Oh, sorry! I am not standing in the spotlight
In this more complex world
Developers are constantly looking for new answers
To solve their problems
So how do you target interactions with users?
Personalized adjustments and customizations?
How to make the most of these emerging
Emerging types of devices?
How to develop a sensible interactive strategy for this situation?
How to make users connect with others
Interact with the surrounding environment?
In the next 20 minutes or so
We will talk about how Google helps you.
Looking for satisfactory answers to these questions
And develop a sound strategy
Let’s first introduce how to tailor the interaction.
This chart shows the data of the United States.
But it also works in many European countries.
Please think about it now.
Next year, users who use your app on their smartphones
60% will also be able to use your app on your tablet
I think this number is quite impressive.
this means
If your service, application or product
Need to rely on user login to provide personalized content or services
Or track the value of your advertising channel
Basically, you need to find a way
On all devices used by your users
Give them an easy and smooth login experience
And Google can help you
Today, I want to introduce you to Smart Lock (password specific)
This is a lightweight API for Android and Chrome.
Mainly used to store your users
Login information used on the web and on Android
It will remember that your users are using email and passwords
Still using Google login or Facebook
Authenticate in your app
If the user performs these actions online
Smart Lock (password specific) will do the same on Android
User-entered credentials
Will also be successfully synchronized in the background
All devices it logs in to
That is sync to Android smartphone tablet and Chrome
Let's take a look at the actual efficacy of this feature.
If you have web content
One of your users has previously been authenticated on the site
But now it’s your first time installing your app.
Then the user will not see the login screen
Or a prompt asking for a password
But will let them log in automatically
We can see that
A partner who uses this feature in the market
Allow 10% of your audience to sign in immediately on Android
Because they have already developed a huge group of login users on the website.
If the user has registered multiple accounts
Smart Lock will ask the user
Sign in with your Gmail account
Still using a Hotmail account to log in?
For you, this means
When the user switches between platforms or devices
They won’t see the login prompt so there won’t be users leaving your app.
Users will appear in your app soon
But you will still meet
User registration for the first time
When a user opens an account in your app
A prompt will appear in the app asking if the user wants to save the password.
Or do you want to sign in with your Google account?
After that, the feature will remember the user's choice.
And provide the same choice when users use your app on a tablet or on a website.
About 50% to 60% of users see the prompt
Will agree with this option
We believe that we can do better
The method is to improve the user experience and prompt process
We have a partner who uses this feature called Orbit.
They found that they logged in via an Android device
User population increased by 5%
And it’s done by just showing this prompt.
Therefore, it is recommended that you work on all different devices.
Confirm the identity of your users
And let them switch devices
Easy to authenticate
Next, I want to give you a brief introduction.
Why notifications are important user interaction strategies
And introduce the utilities we provide
We all saw that notifications are a very important tool.
Ensure that users can keep returning
But if you want to have a substantial impact on attractiveness
You need to ask yourself a few important questions
In order to develop a notification strategy
You need to identify a key goal
Let's take a look at "Share the Meal". What does the developer do?
Their key goal is to raise donations
So when the developer sends you a notification
I hope you can open the app and donate
In addition, they also want to know
The specific environment and time when the system sends notifications
When you receive the notice
May be having breakfast, lunch or dinner
And the time or frequency of sending notifications
May be once a week, once a month or even once a day
After solving the above problem
You still need to figure it out
How to target notifications
Users in different groups?
In addition, you still need to think
What technical resources do you want to invest in?
To actually implement your notification strategy
Google Cloud Messaging is a free notification service provided by Google
Can really help you achieve
First-rate notification strategy
And applies to all use cases
You can use this service to send messages for background thinking
And implementing messaging
As for the use case
You can enable messaging across devices platforms
This way, if someone praises your photo on any device
You will be notified on all devices
The advantage of this service is that it is built on Google infrastructure.
Very reliable when dealing with high message loads
So you don’t have to worry about being unable to
Cover your users
In addition, the service consumes less power
This is great
Because your app doesn't need to fetch data from your server
When implementing the strategy
This service can radically reduce your engineering complexity
And the best part is that this feature is completely free
It has all the features of the beta
And there are no restrictions on use.
I want to focus on an important function below.
Oh, there is a small logo missing here.
There should have been a cloud messaging service logo here.
I want to introduce a new feature that is highly inquiring.
That is the topic messaging function
The logo is here?
You can assign users to individual topics
First, you need to create a list of topics.
They refer to this list as an app marketing list.
Then you can automatically assign users to this list
This allows a group of devices to subscribe to the topic.
Alternatively, you can also ask the user to log in.
At this time, you can ask the user such a small question.
Are you an application marketing manager? Or ask a similar question
Then you can send a message to Google and simply explain
You want to open a new beta test via the topic message
And send relevant messages to the topic app marketing list
Then you don't have to worry anymore
Any subscription management work
Because Google will help you get everything done.
The benefit of this service is
You can do it quickly and efficiently
Implement subscription
Currently, this service is still in beta
Therefore, the maximum number of subscribers per app is 1 million.
The part of tailored interaction has been finished
Next, I will continue to introduce
How to extend your interaction strategy to other devices
Android continues to expand the scope of services
From mobile phones and tablets to TV, wearables and automotive
Android and Play provide you with a platform
But only with apps built by developers
These platforms can really play a real role
And create value for users
Currently, this is still a very new field.
Therefore, you can take advantage of this opportunity.
Thinking about how to target these new devices and platforms
Tailored interactive strategy
We are very much looking forward to seeing
Creative ideas of all of you
When it comes to the Wear platform, I will mention three use cases here.
These use cases are sorted according to the difficulty and complexity of the integration work.
You can refer to these practices
Reach the Wear platform and users of smart watches to use your app again
And interact with them
So the notification function is still very important.
Because most notifications don't need to be set up anymore.
If you already have an Android device
Optimize notifications
Then these notifications can already be used on Wear.
If you use the action buttons to improve your notifications
Then these operations
Will automatically function on the Wear device automatically
In addition, you can also use some great enhancements specifically for Wear.
Such as scratch pads, pages, and voice responses
The dial theme is also a great exposure medium
Because it can make your brand or application
Displayed on the user's watch
Quite conspicuous
Moreover, watches are also the personal devices that users view most often.
So you can apply app related updates
Pushing to the dial theme will have unexpected effects.
The hardest thing to do is to create an app.
So you can build these apps
And let it run on the Wear device
These apps can do almost everything a smartphone app can do.
Therefore, these applications can be used with these applications.
Sensor on Wear device
We will talk about some use cases later.
In order to provide a great Wear experience
We have been innovating since the launch of Wear last year.
In fact, we have made great progress
I want to introduce an important feature in particular.
That is the "always on" feature.
Roughly speaking, this feature can make your app
Always showing it at the top, it consumes very little power
And the update interval is longer
Updated approximately every 10 seconds
Such as running applications
Can show the distance you have ran
Or show the gate information when you walk into the airport
And don’t need to waste too much power
Will not degrade the performance of wearable devices
In addition, we also launched the dial theme
And is an interactive dial theme
In general, you just tap the dial theme
Or tap the custom watch face
Show other content or more related content
For example, just tap the watch face and tap the calendar button.
You can view your day’s schedule
No need to open the app at all
In addition, we have released other upgrades.
For example, we allow apps to use Wi-Fi
This way, this feature can provide you with a lot of convenience when your phone is not around.
You can use built-in GPS. This feature is very important for running applications.
You can also use the Maps API
On the Wear device
Enjoy a great map experience
And we also support iOS now.
Next, I will give a few good examples.
One of them is The Guardian.
Loading time is a bit long
The Guardian will be directly on your watch.
Show notifications for the latest news
If you are interested in this news
You can make a mark
And save this news so that you can read it later on your phone.
City Mapper also has successful use cases
It can plan the route between the two locations for you to travel freely in most major cities.
And the "always on" feature saves power
Eliminate your concerns about running out of power on your way to work in London
American Airlines is also an excellent use case
You can go through your own watch
View all your flight information
This way, when you forget your seat number
You don’t have to take out your phone all the time to check it out.
What's more, you may still have big bags of luggage in your hand.
What's Up is also very well done
They enhanced their Wear app
So sometimes you don’t even have to open your phone
You can reply directly from your watch
Next is the fitness app I talked about before.
You can choose to use the "always on" mode
And check your running distance at any time while running
And the time it takes to run
Then there is the trip, it should be music.
You can browse your playlists smoothly with Spotify
If you are at home your phone is charging with a power plug
And you are walking around again
You can control music playback by pressing the play button
In this way, you can comfortably lie on the sofa.
Without getting up and getting a mobile phone
Next, we will also briefly introduce
TV experience service
We can use Google Cast and AndroidTV
First talk about Cast, this is a technology.
With this technology you can do it wirelessly
Put your favorite entertainment, apps, or websites on your phone or phone
Project to your TV or sound system
Cast is very popular
We sold more than 17 million devices worldwide
You can buy Cast in 35,000 stores in 26 countries.
This is actually a mobile platform
Well catered to consumer trends
And we found
Equipment usage increased by 60% year-on-year
There are already 22,000 apps that support Cast
AndroidTV is well designed for multiple uses
It is to a greater extent for users to enjoy the experience of viewing content on a large screen.
You just sit comfortably on the sofa.
If you don't know what program you want to watch.
Just turn on your smart TV.
Our goal is to create such an experience.
You just have to sit in the living room with ease
Be able to discover new media content
We have some partners
It is itself a TV supplier such as Sony, Philips and Grundig
In addition, we are with set-top boxes and game console manufacturers.
There is also cooperation
So, we launched the Nexus device, NVIDIA
Huawei and Razer devices
Because it is also a huge gaming platform
Technically, the working principle of Cast is
You can use Cast to cast audio and video
You can also develop games that support Google Cast.
So you can build great HTML5 games
Another use case is to extend your app.
So that the user experience of your app can be extended to the second screen
Thus achieving a dual screen experience
To use AndroidTV and our Lean back content library
We will ask you to create a directory browser
And provide card view
And detailed background playing cards
This way, if the user is watching a show in your app.
Turned off your app
The corresponding program will continue to play in the background.
AndroidTV has a very important function
That's what makes it easy for users to discover your content.
Therefore, we recommend that you make your content and apps available for others to search.
And provide users with in-app search capabilities
this point is very important
In addition, you also need to provide us with the right content.
Next, I want to give a brief introduction to Android Auto.
Android Auto started slightly slower
But we have established a partnership with Volkswagen, SEAT and Skoda.
Audi is also about to become our partner
Some of GM's brands such as Vauxhall Automotive
Announced that we will be able to purchase with us in Europe in early 2016.
Support for Android Auto's Pioneer self-provisioning upgrade content
In other words, users can purchase self-contained upgrade content.
In addition, we learned about other manufacturers
We have signed contracts with 28 manufacturers.
Other manufacturers are also about to offer Android Auto services
If you are developing a communication or music application
Then you can take this opportunity
Take a place in the market
In addition, I want to introduce Cardboard quickly.
In short, its function is
Help developers easily create virtual reality experiences
Users only need to use their mobile apps with the open source toolkit provided.
Can experience many common virtual reality features
Such as lens distortion
Correction and head tracking
So this way you can effectively interact with your app.
Expand to different platforms and emerging devices
Finally, I want to give a brief introduction.
How the app interacts with its surroundings
And how users interact with other users around them
Let’s take a brief look
Nearby Proximity API
This is a new technology that Google recently launched.
simply put
You can use this technology to create a great experience
Enable users close to each other to discover each other
Or discover the surrounding beacons
This contains two components
One is the nearby messaging function.
That is, adjacent devices
Easily exchange messages
For example, collaborative editing is like discussing a whiteboard through a conference room.
Or create a group, vote for something
Or disseminate resources
Another component is the nearby connection function
Allow devices using the same network to discover each other
For multiplayer games
The best thing about the Nearby Proximity API is
It works on iOS and Android
Can also interact with beacon devices
And your users don’t need to sign in to use the features.
This is also very good
In addition, you only need to focus on research
The actual use case to be implemented
Google will help you get the rest
We can use Bluetooth, WLAN
And sounds that can be received through the device but are inaudible to the human ear.
To communicate with other devices
At the moment, we have seen some great
Implementation case
For example, E-DJing launched a cool feature
Allow listeners to playlist votes
That is, when the DJ releases the playlist
The audience can vote
What song do they want to listen to next?
Pocket Cast allows two or more users
Publish their subscribed podcasts
Then you can pick from it
And subscribe to podcasts that interest you.
And Trello allows users to share
Nearby bulletin board
This way, you can subscribe to the project bulletin board.
For example, you can subscribe to the bulletin board for other people in this room.
So you can take advantage of this powerful technology
Interact with other users in your app
And enhance your product
Attractive to them
In addition, I still want to talk about beacons.
You can play a little imagination
Think of the beacon as a beacon
It can be added at
On a certain location in the room
They can be applications that use beacons
Provide precise geographic location and environmental cues
For example, we can use beacons to indicate a bus stop somewhere.
In this way, your phone will know
To show the time of the next bus arrival
Or prompt you to prepare your ticket
Or, we can also add beacons to museum exhibits.
Thereby providing information about the exhibits
Additional information or background information
Google can help you with this interaction.
All with the help of the Goolgle beacon platform
The platform consists essentially of three parts
The first is low-cost beacon equipment
These devices must comply with our hardware specifications
To ensure that it works with our API
We use Eddystone as our beacon format.
Eddystone is an open source format produced by Google
This format basically defines three payloads
You can use the device identifier
Provide contextual information to your app
This will interact with them
So you can use this content to create an interactive experience.
Eddystone beacons can broadcast compressed URLs
So you can give users direct access to these URLs
That is, you can place deep links in relevant places in your app.
In addition, such beacons also broadcast telemetry data.
So it will show the temperature in the beacon
And related information such as whether the beacon is moving or not.
You can build services for this type of event.
In addition, we also have the Proximity Beacon API
You can use this API to register a large number of beacons.
And remotely manage beacons
So you don't have to go find your own beacons.
Confirm if they are still working
And is the remaining battery power sufficient?
Finally, I want to bring everyone to look into the future.
What is the future situation?
What is our direction?
That is Brillo and Weave.
We are working hard to make more progress after launching the beacon
And make full use of the Internet of Things
Brillo is actually a networked device
Android platform
In theory, the platform uses our standards so you can easily set up the platform
And devices can communicate as expected
Basically, we can think of Brillo as
Internet of Things operating system
And Weave is the Internet of Things agreement.
It can be between your devices
Provide seamless and secure communication
This communication is not limited to your smartphone and IoT devices.
Can also be done between different devices
In addition, it is also integrated into Google Play.
So from the beginning
Android app developers can go directly
Create great applications based on this system
It ensures that all devices can communicate
We have provided a certification program
To ensure that the equipment meets all standards
This is the end of my speech.
Thank you for your participation.
I hope that everyone knows what I am talking about.
The first is a platform that is now very well functional.
Tailored interaction
This is also the core of your business.
Then, we learned about some emerging platforms like Wear, Smart TV.
Chrome Cast and Cardboard
You must also take these platforms into consideration.
To ensure coverage
Important user
In addition, we also mentioned the online world, beacons and the Internet of Things.
Everyone must start thinking hard
How to reach the target user
How to ensure your users
Will continue to use your app
thank you all!
[applause]
[play music]